Every second of your life,
you are under attack.
Billions of bacteria,
viruses and fungi are trying to make you their Hobo.
Still.
Our bodies have developed a super complex little army with guards and soldiers,
intelligence,
weapons,
factories and communicators to protect you from a well dying for this video.
Let's assume the immune system has 12 different jobs,
for example,
kill enemies,
communicates,
et Cetera,
and it has 21 different cells and two protein forces.
These cells have up to four different jobs.
Let's assign them.
Hey,
are the interactions.
Now let's make this understandable.
First of all,
let's add colors to the jobs.
Now let's illustrate the cells.
The central color represents the main job of the cell while the surrounding ones
represents secondary duties.
Now the immune system looks like this.
Now the interactions isn't this complexity just awesome.
For this video,
we will only talk about these cells and ignore the rest.
So what happens in the case of an infection?
Okay,
beautiful day when suddenly oh wild rusty nail or pairs and you catch yourself.
The first barrier of the immune system is breached.
Your skin nearby bacteria seize on the opportunity and Auntie your wound.
They start using up the body's resources and double their numbers about every 20
minutes.
At first they fly under the radar,
but when a certain bacteria population is reached,
they changed their behavior and start to damage the body.
By changing the environment around them,
the immune system has to stop them as fast as possible.
The first of all,
your guard cells known as macrophages intervene.
They are huge cells that God every border region of the body,
most of the time that they alone can suffocate and attack because they can
devour up to 100 intruders each.
They swallow the intruder hole and trap it inside a membrane.
Then the enemy gets broken down by enzymes and is killed on top of that.
They cause inflammation by ordering the blood vessels to release water into the
battlefield,
so fighting becomes easier.
You notice this as a very mild swelling.
When the Metro phages fight for too long,
they call in heavy backup by releasing messenger proteins that communicate
location and urgency.
Neutrophils leave their patrol routes in the blood and a move to the
battlefield.
The neutrophils fight so furiously that they kill healthy cells in the process.
On top of that,
they generate barriers that trap and kill the bacteria.
They are indeed say deadly that they evolved to commit suicide after five days
to prevent them from causing too much damage.
If this is not enough to stop the invasion,
the brain of the immune system kicks in,
the dendritic cell gets active,
it reacts to the signals of the soldiers and starts collecting samples from the
enemies.
They ripped them into pieces and present the parts on their outer layer.
Now the dendritic cell makes eight decision should they call for antivirus
forces that eradicate with infected body cells or an army of bacteria killers.
In this case,
antibacteria force is unnecessary.
It then travels to the closest lymph node in about a day here.
Billions of helper and killer t cells are waiting to be activated when t cells
are born may go through a difficult and complicated training process and only a
quarter survives.
The surviving cells are equipped with a specific setup and the dendritic cell is
on its way looking for a helper t cell with a setup that's just right.
It's looking for a helper t cell.
The combined to the parts of the intruders,
which the dendritic cell has presented on its membrane.
When it finally finds one,
that chain reaction takes place.
The helper t cell is activated.
It quickly duplicates thousands of times,
some become memory t cells that stay in the lymph node and we'll make you
practically immune against this enemy.
Some traveled to the field of battle to how bout,
and the third group goes on to travel to the center that inf note to activate a
very powerful weapons factory like the t cells.
They're born with a specific setup and when a B cell and the t cell with the
same setup meet hell breaks loose,
the B cell duplicates rapidly and starts producing millions of little weapons.
They work so hard that they would literally die from exhaustion very fast.
Here helper t cells play another important role.
They stimulate the hard working in factories and tell them don't die yet.
We still need you keep going.
There's also ensures that the factories diathermy infection is over,
so the body doesn't waste energy or hurt itself,
but what is produced by the B cells?
You've heard of them.
Of course,
antibodies,
little proteins that are engineered to bind to the surface of the specific
intruder.
There are even different kinds of antibodies that have slightly different jobs.
The helper t cells tell the plasma cells which type is needed the most in this
particular invasion.
Millions of them flood the bladder and saturate the body.
Meanwhile,
of the site of infection,
the situation is getting Dyer.
The intruders have multiplied in number and start hurting the body guard and a
tech sales fight hard but also die in the process.
Help a t-cells support them by ordering them to be more aggressive and to stay
alive longer,
but without help.
They can't overwhelm the bacteria.
But now the second line of Defense arrives.
Billions of antibodies flood the battlefield and disabled lots of the intruders
rendering them helpless or killing them in the process.
They also stunned the bacteria and make them an easy target.
They're back is built to connect to killer cells so they can connect and kill
the enemy more easily.
Macrophages are especially good at numbing up the bacteria which antibodies have
attached to.
Now the balance shifts in a team effort.
The infection is wiped out.
At this point,
millions of body cells have already died.
No big deal.
The losses are quickly replenished.
Most immune cells are now useless and without the constant signals,
they commit suicide,
so as to waste any resources,
but some stay behind the memory cells.
If this enemies encountered ever again in the future,
they will be ready for it and probably can it before you even notice.
This was a very,
very simplified explanation of parts of the immune system at work.
Can you imagine how complex his system is even at this level?
When we ignore so many players and all the chemistry,
life is awfully complicated,
but if we take the time to understand it,
we always encounter endless wonders and great beauty.